well Claire definitively said she did
not want her guys on cammy oh yeah and a
lot of people said she's got to be
talking about Matt James because he is
on cameo now Matt came out and said hey
I'm donating these proceeds charity
Claire doubled down she said respect the
rules and wondering where you fall on if
a contestant can be on kami
first of all I talked to Claire and I
think what first of all everyone relaxed
about the whole charity thing Claire's
not against charity she's not against
Matt doing charity that's fantastic and
Matt good on you for doing something
during this quarantine that that's
positive but with that said I think what
Claire's talking about it she's not
specifically talking about Matt she's
just saying she's living under a certain
set of guidelines and rules because
she's the Bachelorette she's kind of
already in our family and she's been
respecting that these guys aren't living
under those guidelines because they're
not really a part of our thing yet and
so they're kind of out living their life
and they're kind of using having been
picked to be on The Bachelorette is a
bit of a bouncing point and using that
and so I think she's just like look I
wish everybody would respect the rules
and we all play by the same rules so
when you come in there is a sense of
innocence and Ava Tay and we can
actually go through this but you know
she's not calling anybody in particular
out she's not mad at Matt and it's all
good and she's not mad at anybody doing
things for charity first of all don't
get mad at Claire
so is Matt still gonna be on this season
as far as I know yeah I mean I have not
heard anything different that's up to
Matt as well though I mean I don't know
if he wants to do this after quarantine
who knows but as far as I know yes as a
fan as a viewer I want to watch Matt and
Claire have this discussion on camera
now about I don't know Matt at all I
don't know I've seen him on whatever
Instagram or whatever they do but he
seems like a nice guy why not and he
seemed like I think I did see something
where he said I'm really excited to meet
meet Claire I'm like super that's all we
want
so have you discussed with Claire at all
but obviously she must be watching these
guys she's looking at what her guys are
doing on Instagram I had that
conversation why I might have had it
with you early on when we talked to her
one night when we were facetiming
and I just how are you doing and I said
tell me you didn't just jump online and
check some of these guys now she's like
oh I totally did but I haven't talked to
her about that since honestly since then
you know when i text with peter or or
any of these people it's just checking
in and making sure they're doing ok and
because on a very real level players
alone and she's up quarantine by herself
and and i know for a lot of people it's
emotional and it's tough and we're going
through a lot and so i'm just checking
on these people seeing how they're doing
[Music]